made him not only is he just winning a
bi position but he's gonna May to be a
queen III check followed by night to see
one I think will be what we see watch
out for g6 checked by white right that
will be that would be a problem the one
way for Carlson is take a check okay oh
okay he will e he's just being a good
Russian schoolboy rushing schoolboys no
to always repeat as soon as you can
Magnus is about to throw in the towel I
can see by his body language oh the
night mb3 saying we have our first we
have our first made on the board of the
day Magnus gets his bell rung we don't
miss an opportunity to do it ourselves
always ring that bell any time someone
gets checkmated and grishnack jumps out
to a 200 lead it's time for them to
rematch and ja and the players should do
that yeah so I mean really gray shirt
with a very strong showing in the first
two games is absolutely streaming
impressive and now Grisha gets the white
pieces for the first time in classical
chest normal not 960 chest and he you
know he started d4 and we'll see how he
progresses but what a showing by crook I
mean so far so far so good right he's up
- oh we show everybody the score here
we've been focused on zoning in on the
action that you know and all the facial
expressions these players have but here
we get here we can see the score is is -
OH
and then here we're gonna we're gonna
have the best of both worlds now let's
let's keep our eye on these players and
all the emotions they'll show and keep
an eye on the score I have a question
for you Danny do you think max has ever
been down to zero in a match like in the
history of his life or like you know
last six years right maybe like like
since he was seven yelled no yeah I
don't know I mean I would I would have
to say no I think the match is still
young but if anything was going to get
people on the edge of their seats it's
it's the fact that oMG will the
strongest player in history actually go
down in this match right the you know
it's been said by the commentators I'm
not gonna toot my own horn as yes I am I
I picked grishnack to pull the massive
upset in this match of course knowing
Carlson is the favorite that he is but
but Carlson said too
to chess comm that he believes Grichuk
is is one of the three hardest opponents
he has I could ever possibly play so and
we already know as we've as we've
reviewed and showed you before the match
started the head-to-head score against
these players is not as lopsided as you
might think so so there you go that is
why we had our criticism so to speak of
the lopsided votes here but okay the
match is still young Magnus Carlsen is
still Magnus Carlsen I do not expect him
to I do not expect him to go on complete
tilt here but then again he's down to oh
now he's black in a worse middle game
yep right you have to stop the bleeding
so to speak you don't want to lose this
game even a draw as sort of a successful
result right now for Magnus absolutely
and speaking of Brooke he's not only the
current world book champion but the
three-time world blitz champion and
Magnus has actually only won two world
let's championships himself so I'm not
saying that demonstrates the growth
shock is the better Bliss player but
does show that he's a dominant player in
his own right and as you just mention
about the position we have on the board
this is a worse middle game for black
and the main reason why is the 9mb one
can easily infiltrate d5 that nine of
six has to reroute itself and that pony
can't get there quick enough right and
and so it ends up happening is you're
either dealing with the middle game
where your poet instantly has more
pieces or you're committing to the
long-term advantage of your opponent by
giving them a protected pass pawn
positionally a pawn that is protected by
another pawn is one of the most
irritating things to deal with right
it's like having a thorn in your shoe it
makes you gotta take off your shoe your
sock everything desperately search for
what's been poking you in your foot then
a protective passed pawn is is really
hard to get rid of yeah now here in
Arizona that might not be a thorn that
would be a cactus needle in your foot so
you don't want to deal with that no
exactly and now so okay we're going to
head to a middle game where white is
going to be a little bit better Magnus
is preparing to have to eliminate that
pony
Grichuk is preparing for the right time
to enter into d5 I don't see a better
time than now yeah I was going to say
here we go and let's force the capture
white has the bishop pair and and the
potential pressure on c5 and could we
possibly see Carlsen go down 303 in this
match well you know this is a really bad
position
black it's not that you know the
materials even it doesn't look so
horrible the problem is there are no
real concrete plans and what is it going
to piling a pressure the light square
bishop can prove very dominant for
example black has a very difficult time
going to pawn to b6 because that Bishop
on e tube then go to a6 and kick the
roof from the C file so fighting for the
C file is actually not easy for black
and even if you get this Pony to d6 well
white did somebody goes pawn to f3 the
c5 pawn will always be a target
and at some point white will consider
you in here Bishop c4 same ideas Bishop
Agnes shaking his head he's just not
happy with himself deeply because now he
lost a pawn he's blundering he's
blundering Grichuk knows it sasha is he
zoned in right now I he's uh I'm trying
to think of something better to say
about his expression but I mean has he
blinked in the last 45 minutes I don't
think he has and he's going to gobble up
c5 and put Carlsen completely on his
heels potentially bringing the world
champion to an oh free deficit in the
match we still have a long way to go
folks an hour in the 5 minute portion
and that's before we get to the 3 minute
portion but so far so good if you are a
fan of the reigning world blitz champion
Sasha Grichuk the knight establishing on
d6 you know this is just good positional
chess aron nimzowitsch would be proud
unlike other pieces who struggle there
the knight actually thrives and
blockading positions but the problem is
you're down and protected passed pawn
that is completely protected the C file
is owned by white currently it's the
only open file on the board I'm in pain
if I'm a Carlsen fan right now yeah and
actually I think Magnus did well to get
here after what looked like a really
tough position he was shaking his head
and now all of a sudden what Grichuk
wants is to create another weakness it's
very important yes black is very solid
f5 but Magnus is trying to gain space
put pressure on now the pawn to e4 is
already under attack but is it really is
the essential questions if I grow a
bishop h3 I always throw my bishop in
the e6 check at the right moment so
unfortunately for Magnus despite trying
to take back the C file he's not really
getting it I just doubled my rooks on
the C file now I think it's recommended
rook to c1 and actually G for it I'd be
very tempted to play as well here
and here it is and the problem from
black is now this bishop is going to try
to make its way into e6 and some magnets
being smart of G takes at five k f6 is
not so clear so you know it's a good
battle right now I think Magnus is doing
his best to try to save this half point
but we shook just what dominant
performance so far absolutely and you
know he he but we did say before this
game started that probably even a draw
would be considered a successful result
for Magnus right being down o2 you don't
want to go on a losing streak go and go
free so I like the way he's defended
this position as ugly as this looks you
know if he if he's able to win back this
pawn safely and somehow simplify into a
rook ending he might be able to hold
right so that's all Carlson has on his
mind right now hold this position where
he was worse from the get-go and give
himself a chance to win his white yeah
some some tactics might Bend me I'm
thinking rook e1 now and if Knight takes
a five minute some f4 moves that will
get it gets really risky it from black
with it you've been listening to Big
Willie I like it and there's always some
some issues upon me five nine and a5 is
very loose and the point everybody is if
F takes rook e6 check as a hanging
Knight
amazing amazing stuff here I tried our
new analysis of moving the pieces but
looks like we have a little bit of a bug
I'm stuck in analysis mode even though
the players are playing always helping
developers are listening so let's see if
I okay so I press the reset button and I
get back there maybe not a bug actually
I like it I like it not a bug it's a
feature that's the old saying that
developers have for you know this is
this is great defense right now you can
tell Grichuk is is a little bit
frustrated you know looking at his
facial expression confirmed by our
assistant here that the evaluation has
gone down from nearly +2 to about half a
pawn as Magnus has defended really well
getting activity for his pieces and Greg
looks hyper-focus look guy he's set up
in his chair so is the top of his head I
was invisible to us but you know he's
really fine trying to find a way to
increase his advantage
but it's going to say that was a risky
idea is he really putting himself in
position well yeah if this tactic if
king of two rook takes g4 followed by
ninety four check forking the rook
that's a trap town population grish ik
he went for it oh he blonde went for him
he started the Carlson he smiles and
sticks out his tongue classic classic
Magnus and in fact he probably should've
taken with the other rook it was a
stronger rook the even stronger rook
eight takes g4 would have kept this rook
on the very dangerous third rank okay
Carlson is likely to go on to win talk
about a swing of events here we had
nearly a plus-two advantage for the
Russian we're now at a nearly a plus two
advantage for the Norwegian that is how
things turn around and blitz although
this is not the easiest thing name to
win yet right
lots of pawns to deal with whole lot of
pawns to deal with not a lot of time
the problem for grishnack is he is also
running out of time on the clock love
the animation from Magnus that's why we
have the players webcam dub when would
you ever see Magnus Carlsen stick his
tongue out in a real game I challenge
you over the board chess proved to me
you're still as entertaining his online
chess that was that was hilarious no
that was great and well you know in some
ways is payback because there was
discussion about how Grichuk won the ICC
back between the two and the IC
championship was two and a half one
Avenue Rick's favorite but he was
actually down a full-piece in that game
and we said as we said the advantage was
+2 at some point from this what's
happening here though because Magnus
played for a mating net made a ton of
sense but if he continued on that track
Greg would Queen with check just in time
winning the game so Carlson has to
abandon that plan but now these two
pawns are still going to be a little bit
tricky to clean up um Grichuk not
thrilled at this point obviously he led
an O three chance go away speaking of
which at Samuel Maxton on Twitter said
speaking of zoned in Magnus looked
totally preoccupied in the first few
games but nothing like at a potential oh
three deficit to turn things around and
there's a cool tactic here up g7 if
Knight e6 doesn't actually attack the
rook because if you take my row can go
h7 I can actually leave my rook there
for a move and nine to five is of course
the better option
because now kini too doesn't attack any
pawns and well this is desperation yeah
now it's desperation time there's no way
that this epon and the potential mating
Nets threats that the knight and pawn
create with the rook are not going to
decide this game I expect Rick to throw
in the towel here momentarily and does
that say that you're good at predicting
moves I'm good at predicting body
language he takes a sip of his coffee
says well you got to forget that one
Sasha yeah that makes us the perfect duo
because if I take your ability to read a
body language and we do the moves I mean
we're going to be the let's play we're
going to be dangerous players if only if
only that worked that way